Ó, desafio de jejum 5:7 começa
segunda-feira agora. Só que antes de eu
de eu falar com você sobre o desafio, eu
preciso de falar uma coisa que
ninguém tá te falando.
Você tá aqui.
Você se inscreveu, você assistiu as três
aulas prévias,
você tá se preparando.
Só que ao mesmo tempo, eu sei que tem
uma parte de você que tá assim, ó:
"Ai, mas eu já tentei tanta coisa, já
fiz um monte de dieta. Ah, eu já passei
por um monte de médico, um monte de
nutri.
Ah, vamos entrar e ver o que que
acontece dessa vez". Eu sei que você tá
pensando isso. Eu não vou fingir que
isso não existe, porque esse ceticismo
seu, essa sua falta de de crença em você
mesma, de crença num trabalho de de
emagrecimento, ele é com completamente
legítimo, porque você viveu anos
tentando.
E os anos te ensinaram que
o esforço nem sempre vai te trazer o
resultado que você quer. E eu não vou te
pedir pra desligar essa parte, mas eu
vou te mostrar o porquê que ela existe e
porquê que ela
não é culpa sua.
Porque se você tá aqui com a barriga que
não saiu, com cansaço que não passa, com
os exames que voltam
normais, né, quando você vai lá no
no médico, mas o seu corpo claramente
não tá bem,
isso não é falta de força de vontade.
Isso é biologia, isso é hormônio. É um
mecanismo. E a gente vai falar sobre
isso agora. Olha só o que essa pesquisa
que eu fiz com mulheres que estão
participando desse desafio mostra:
quatro em cada 10 mulheres tem gordura
no fígado. Quase 50% tem alguma questão
de tireoide, confirmada ou suspeita em
cima dos sintomas. Mais de três em cada
10 mulheres afirmou que tem resistência
à insulina.
Mas com certeza, essa questão de
resistência insulínica tem muito mais
mulheres do que isso. E quase uma em
cada três
uma em cada três não tem nenhum
diagnóstico. Exames voltam normais, mas
a
barriga continua, a energia não volta e
ninguém consegue te explicar o porquê
disso.
Sabe o que que todas essas mulheres tem
em comum?
Nenhum protocolo
que elas tentaram antes foi desenvolvido
para o metabolismo delas.
Foi desenvolvido para o metabolismo
genérico, que não existe.
Aí você faz low carb, cetogênica, jejum
intermitente, aí vai na academia, faz
uma caminhada, uma aula de zumba,
corta carboidrato, corta carboidrato,
passa a comer muito pouco, todas essas
coisas funcionam para quem tem a base
hormonal metabólica em ordem.
Agora para quem tem gordura no fígado,
para quem tem tireoide comprometida,
para quem tem insulina cronicamente
elevada, sabe o que acontece?
O resultado é parcial, o resultado é
lento, às vezes o resultado não vem.
Então não é porque você fez errado,
é porque o método
não foi feito para você.
O jejum metabólico que a gente vai
aplicar essa semana, esse sim foi feito
para você.
Então presta atenção nisso, porque
baseado em todo o questionário do
desafio que você preencheu,
você já recebeu seu pré-diagnóstico
médico e entendeu que existem coisas no
seu organismo que possivelmente estão o
quê?
Estão fora do lugar,
não estão funcionando bem.
Coisas que às vezes o seu exame não
pega,
seu exame não vê.
Aí o médico tradicional fala que está
tudo bem com seus exames.
Só que você sente um monte de coisas
todos os dias.
E por sentir,
você sabe que tem alguma coisa que não
está legal com você.
E aí há muito tempo você convive com
isso, você lida com isso, você vai
empurrando com a barriga, sempre
priorizando a casa, o marido, o filho,
os netos, os outros,
mas você nunca, você fica no final da
fila de prioridade, que chegou a hora
disso tudo mudar. Segunda será o grande
dia da virada e eu como médico que já
acompanhou milhares de mulheres,
eu não
que lá na frente você pague a conta
do descaso
que você mesma impôs a você.
Durante o desafio
você vai ter a sua dieta, você vai
aprender a analisar os seus exames, você
vai conhecer um novo universo, um novo
mundo que diz respeito à saúde e e o que
acontece dentro de você.
Então sim
terá muita coisa prática, mudanças de
hábitos
coisas que você [roncando] vai conseguir
implementar no seu dia a dia e você vai
poder ver isso, o poder da transformação
em apenas sete dias e ao final da semana
você você vai notar um corpo diferente,
muitas vezes melhor do que você começou,
mas não só em questão de quilos, mas em
questão de saúde, de vitalidade. Sete
dias é o tempo que eu te peço de
dedicação a você.
Então agora
temos uma coisa que é tão ou até mais
importante do que as mudanças de
hábitos, que é
que é a mudança da sua mentalidade.
E essa
é a mudança que vai ser capaz de tornar
o emagrecimento definitivo.
De abolir o efeito sanfona da sua vida.
Nós também vamos trabalhar essa camada.
E essa camada, eu eu não quero esperar
segunda-feira para a gente começar a
tratar. Eu quero começar hoje, quero
começar agora aliás. Então agora eu vou
te pedir duas coisas simples
para que o processo seja
leve, gradual, gostoso. E a primeira
coisa é, eu quero que você escreva uma
carta para o seu eu do futuro. O eu do
futuro não muito longe, daqui sete dias.
Então reflete sobre
daqui a sete dias, você vai lá, escreve
essa carta. Daqui a sete dias, depois do
desafio funcionar para mim, você vai
escrever isso para você.
O que que vai ser diferente na minha
vida?
Não precisa falar sobre barriga, não
precisa falar, você pode falar sobre
qualidade de vida, como que você quer
acordar, a roupa que você quer servir, a
energia que você quer ter para fazer
algo que parece, às vezes, pesado
demais,
como, por exemplo, às vezes, brincar com
os filhos, passear com os netos, passar
pano na casa,
ou se olhar no espelho, se sentir mais
bonita, com mais energia, mais
vitalidade, sentir uma coisa diferente.
E reflita sobre aquilo que mais te
incomoda hoje, ou sobre aquilo que você
quer mudar, que você mais deseja. Não
importa se parece pequeno, não importa
se é grande, não parece, não importa se
parece bobo, essa carta é sua, é uma
carta para você mesma. E no final dessa
aula, vou deixar um espaço aqui para
você poder escrever essa carta, para que
ela fique guardada. E lá no último dia
do desafio, eu vou te pedir para você
comparar o que você está sentindo
e com o que eu vou te mostrar que a
gente vai encontrar em mulheres
exatamente com o mesmo perfil que o seu.
Então, reflita.
E no final dessa aula,
você escreve essa carta.
Entendido? Isso é muito poderoso para a
gente começar a destravar isso daqui.
A segunda coisa é, que eu quero que você
faça é, vá lá no seu guarda-roupa,
procura uma roupa que você ama. Pode ser
um vestido, uma calça, uma blusa, um
short,
mas que ela está apertada e que parou de
servir em você.
Mas que quando você olha para ela, para
essa roupa, você pensa: "Ai, meu Deus,
quando eu entrar nessa roupa, eu vou
sentir que eu venci".
Então, agora,
coloca essa roupa num lugar que você vai
ver todo dia nessa semana. Pode ser na
cadeira, no quarto, pendurada, pode ser
lá no seu banheiro,
em algum lugar, pendurada na porta do
armário, coloca essa roupa.
E você tem que ver essa roupa todo dia.
Então, todo dia o seu olho tem que
passar por essa roupa, tem que enxergar
essa roupa.
Porque isso vai funcionar como um
amuleto, um despertador aqui no seu
cérebro. E esse, então, é o seu amuleto
dessa semana. Não é sobre tamanho, é
sobre o que essa roupa representa.
Representa a versão de você que está
chegando. E toda vez que a semana pesar
para você,
você vai lá, olha para o seu amuleto e
lembra:
"É por isso aqui".
E no dessa aula você também vai poder me
mandar uma foto da roupa que você
escolheu junto com a carta
e eu quero saber qual que é seu amuleto.
E deixa eu te falar, olha só, deixa eu
te falar como que vai ser.
No domingo
lá no último dia do desafio você vai
acordar
e antes de olhar pra balança
você vai se olhar no espelho.
Você vai se observar, eu quero que você
se enxergue, eu quero que você se note.
Eu quero que você olhe o inchaço que
tava na barriga desde quando você
iniciou, o que que mudou.
Tá menor a barriga, o inchaço. Você vai
tocar no seu corpo. Eu quero que você se
pegue, quando foi a última vez que você
pegou no seu corpo?
Eu quero que você sinta algo diferente
acontecendo com você. Você vai notar que
tem
mais energia do que nos últimos meses,
mas não é uma energia artificial de
cafeína, de estimulante, energia do seu
metabolismo trabalhando pra você, do seu
organismo utilizando gordura corporal
como fonte de energia de verdade. E eu
sei que hoje
essa cena do seu corpo perdendo gordura
parece um pouco distante, mas você vai
tá lá no domingo e vai lembrar do que eu
te contei nesse momento agora.
E tem uma coisa que eu preciso te falar
antes de segunda-feira.
O que você vai viver nessa semana é o
start, tá?
A gente vai dar um reset.
O jejum metabólico ele vai organizar
essa sua base hormonal metabólica. Você
vai começar, a gente vai começar a
trabalhar a sua insulina, melhorar a
função de fígado, de tireóide, de
cortisol. Sete dias é o tempo que eu
preciso pra que você sinta que tem um
caminho diferente, pra que você sinta
que seu corpo consegue trabalhar pra
você.
E esse é o meu compromisso com esse
desafio, te dar
exatamente esse reset metabólico em
você. E eu sei que nesse momento pra
muitas participantes do desafio já
começam a surgir alguma algumas
questões, surgiu uma certa ansiedade
sobre o que fazer depois, porque você
vai entrar
num verdadeiro universo paralelo, um
mundo paralelo onde você vai aprender
coisas e você vai passar por
transformações que você nunca passou na
sua vida.
Eu tenho certeza que tudo que você vai
ter é melhor do que qualquer consulta
que você fez. Mas eu quero adiantar que
existe um próximo passo. Existe uma
forma de você continuar comigo tratando
cada um desses problemas que a gente vai
identificar durante o desafio, que é
dentro do meu programa de emagrecimento
feminino, que é o PEF 360.
Ele, o PEF 360, é um programa que ele
vai mais a fundo. Ele não trabalha só no
no comportamento alimentar, ele trabalha
mais a fundo o quê? Na sua base hormonal
metabólica, de forma completa, com
acompanhamento, com análise dos seus
exames, ciclagem de dietas e com
indicações do que você precisa tratar em
cada um dos problemas, para você
continuar emagrecendo e se manter magra
e saudável de forma definitiva. Mas isso
é uma conversa lá para o final do
desafio, onde eu vou te explicar no
detalhe como tudo funciona e, de
verdade, se fizer sentido para você,
como participante do desafio, você vai
ter uma oportunidade de aplicar para uma
vaga comigo antes de todo o mundo,
porque elas são
limitadas.
Ó, é um benefício exclusivo para quem
participa do desafio do jejum 5 e 7. E
eu tô te falando isso agora para você
não deixar a ansiedade atrapalhar o seu
processo, porque agora não é hora de
você pensar no depois. Existe um depois,
mas ele vai vir na hora certa se fizer
sentido para você. Agora é hora de você
fazer os exercícios que eu te pedi. E o
mais importante, aparecer na
segunda-feira às 7:00 em jejum, pronta
para você sentir a diferença. Então,
vamos recapitular o que acontece agora.
Hoje à noite você escreve a carta para o
seu eu do futuro e eu vou deixar um
formulário embaixo desse vídeo aqui, ó,
para que você possa escrever a sua carta
e eu também vou guardar ela para você.
Então, escolhe o seu amuleto, deixa ele
num lugar visível na sua casa, Deixa em
cima da cama, no seu quarto, no
banheiro, no guarda-roupa, para que
você possa ver todos os dias do desafio.
No sábado, você tem que assistir a aula
o dia D que eu vou liberar. Lá eu vou te
mostrar tudo, os cardápios, as dietas,
os materiais, como você utiliza tudo.
Domingo à noite
começa o seu jejum.
Sua última refeição
é o início do processo de jejum que a
gente vai quebrar segunda-feira 7:00 da
manhã. Você vai estar comigo ao vivo
em jejum
pronta para receber a primeira chave do
seu emagrecimento. Sete dias, sete aulas
e na sexta-feira
o que vem depois.
Você chegou no momento certo e eu te
vejo na segunda-feira.